thank you
[Music]
this is happening in Busan South Korea a
23 year old woman her name's Jung she
signs up for a tutoring app in search of
an English tutor for her daughter
I don't want to do this anymore
[Laughter]
Okay so
um so then you know it's kind of like
you know those apps where it's like
peer-to-peer kind of thing where you
like go oh I'm looking for this thing
almost like taskrabbit a little bit but
it's for tutors so this 20 year old
woman accepts the job and she goes yeah
send your daughter over to my house I
will tutor her for English no problem so
then what Jung does
she doesn't really even have a daughter
she goes and she buys a fake high school
girl uniform so that she looks like the
daughter she goes to this person's house
this 20 year old uh woman that accepted
the job she rings the doorbell that
woman thinks she's the daughter Zhang
then enters the home and then stabs the
tutor to death and dismembers her entire
body
only because my bosses are telling me to
do what you're hired to do laugh
so then she takes all the body parts she
chops it up and she packs it into a
suitcase and then she uh she calls the
taxi
um she gets the victim's phone and all
her things to make it look like the
victim left the house on her own you
know like if they leave a phone then
they know something's wrong so he takes
all the stuff she puts everything in the
suitcase uh the taxi takes her to the
river where she like dumps all the stuff
or seemingly all of it uh the taxi
driver notices that she's a little
[__] weird so he calls up he's like
why is this 50 year old woman in a
school girl
yeah he calls the cops uh they look into
it and they discover at her house that
she has some more of the body parts uh
at her home oh my God and then they end
up arresting her for the murder of this
you know poor girl they ask her why did
you do it
she says
she was curious and wanted to see what
killing was like after watching shows
about murder
whoa yeah it's so rare to have oh
isn't it rare to have like
girl like psychopath Killers like that
yeah it's super rare super rare I mean
it's out there it is because when you
see the list of uh psycho Killers
there's like
two ladies and then like hundreds of
guys and you know what's funny too
because they're all [__] nurses
oh really a lot of those like female
serial killers are all nurses huh maybe
a correlation wow or is that just your
hate for care workers probably that my
bias for nurses so a little bit of a
background about who this girl is um she
so they describe her as a super
reclusive person like she doesn't talk
to anybody she doesn't really have
friends oh the girl that chopped up the
other girl doesn't talk to anybody
she [__] with that she after
graduating high school five years ago
she just never got a job and she just
stayed home all the time how does she
[__] even live dude her parents oh
yeah
see jobless like people in the house you
gotta be careful you gotta have a job
dude gotta get a job if she got a job
she wouldn't have time to watch killer
films and then she wouldn't be curious
she'd just be too busy working
yeah you gotta have something to do
every day she definitely I feel like I
feel like when this happens and let's
say like a girl does something like this
and chat or guy and they say like oh I
saw a movie about it I wanted to try it
I think
the movie was not the reason you're
already [__] kooky in the half they
could they talked themselves into saying
that whatever they got in their brain
that's just how it processes information
that's true because if she was um if she
had a job making Korean corn dogs you
know it's so cute but it's so good it's
got the potatoes you know what if
instead of watching serial killer
documentaries she watched like chops and
she was like I'm gonna be a [__] Chef
like what if she was curious about that
you know that would have been better
dude honestly yeah instead if like
psychologically you could kind of get in
the brain of like a youth and notice
like well this person has serial killer
Tendencies we need to like flip the
script and get that energy directed
towards something positive that would be
amazing people would be incredible at
skills yeah because some of these
killers if that energy was directed a
different direction how awesome would
they be right
or I mean like we do need people to kill
like I could have just
that's looking at the bright side oh
they could be an assassin for the
government yeah you could have been
I mean yeah you could have been a spy
like yeah but a spy do the same thing
she wasn't very good yeah she was
terrible she was very good shot
that's your first gig yeah everyone
[__] up their first gig yeah you gotta
fail to learn yeah see you gotta feel up
yeah she got the first times she got
this she got the costume the disguise
and then she went up to the mark she did
the job but the cleaning was [__] up
yeah you think Dexter would have done
good he would have got all those kills
if he didn't have his dad guiding him a
mentor she got no Mentor so there's two
places where she messed up right her
behavior in the taxi yeah and the fact
that she had evidence in her home yeah
why did you drive you drive your own car
so what what do you think she could have
done to fix the taxi problem join the
CIA because they'll be The Driver yeah
I don't know
just watch more watch more different
variety of [__] murder mysteries
trigger to why the she should have
killed the taxi driver too and then take
the car so now now you could like go
dump the body because she needs more
experience right she only got one kill
she needs to get a second interesting
God I wonder what it was when the taxi
driver was like this [__] is weird well
that's what's funny is that she's
probably already weird without even
having killed somebody yeah call the
police she's so weird so she must have
not only been weird but to an extent to
get him to actually call the police
instead of just being like Oh that chick
was weird maybe she had blood on her
yeah she might have been sweating
profusely like pale skin or like just
been through some or she was just
sitting in the backseat like this
you know like just
have you guys ever ran into like weird
people to where you're like
oh
something's so off about you yeah I'm
either gonna have to call the cops or
kill you
yeah you know one or the other you know
what I kind of don't like about
how I personally think so the way they
describe her at the end how she's this
person that doesn't talk to you on is
really quiet keeps yourself uh never did
anything
I'm scared of those types of people just
generally I always think they're gonna
snap yeah and it's kind of like
discriminatory but I can't help it I'm
scared of people that are like
anti-socially like you know rocking back
and forth well I'm sure you've met
enough people that are like that to get
like a consistent Vibe where you go yeah
this is not for me where do you meet
people like that you know like if you're
just out some or I guess like if you're
uh meet and greets if you're at like
Dave and Busters and you're you know you
just see ran to someone in the Jurassic
Park game and they won't get out of the
seat that
[Laughter]
anytime I'm in a weird situation I just
leave even if I'm like let's say I'm
jogging
and then like I'm like jogging I go like
that I'm like what the [__] and it's
like just feels weird I just immediately
cross the street and I go the other
direction like a very inconvenient turn
just to see if there's to see what they
would do
and usually they're like on their own
way or whatever yeah like you remember
when I was working in uh Singapore and I
was dancing in the small there was just
like kind of weird kid that would visit
me every day and he wasn't like a kid he
was like probably my age but he
definitely had like a weirdness about
him and he would just like stand there
just staring at me but he was like he
said he was a fan and then like every
once in a while like he would just go
and then everyone around would have to
go hey come down come down and I'll be
like yo I don't want this got to be
coming around is that the handsome Ryan
yeah he would he would say that in my
ear he would go oh my handsome Ryan my
hand said Ryan should you have a
Singaporean accent yeah [__] and he
would go what kind of movies do you like
oh my God yeah and then I would did you
feel like thank you for calling me
handsome I was just trying to I was just
trying to be nice because I didn't know
like what the deal was and then we I had
like a Indian uh host this Indian guy
who was like taking care of me and the
Indian even the Indian guy was like yo
that guy needs to you know and then
every every day he would come by and go
what kind of movie do you like and the
Indian guy she shoved them away one day
he went any movie he likes let's go
all the movies he likes like all movies
yeah and then he and then he would like
leave and then he would just be punching
the air the whole way out of the mall
and it was just like really maybe he was
fighting off demons for you yeah but
again like it's one of the situations
where like I feel like that was probably
20 years ago 15 years ago now I feel
like I would be the bad guy for being
like yo let's not be around this dude
it'd be kind of discriminatory I feel
it's not technically committing a crime
he's not doing anything legal but he
carries the traits of a person that
could be a danger yeah but like when
you're in that moment and you're
actually interacting with that person
it's not just you that feels it too like
the fact that the Indian guy was like
feeling that yeah it's very validating
in a lot of ways because it's like you
know when there's a creep amongst like
normal folks because the you could feel
Vibes and [__] that [__] changes oh 100
but then again like I feel like a lot of
the time we give nowadays I'm gonna say
we give people a little bit too much of
a pass that they kind of end up skirting
through what used to be social
barricades to where they go not you you
know what I mean but then now it's like
yeah come on in and then all of a sudden
disaster strikes and everyone's you know
getting jugulars cut yeah like a guy
going into like a gun store yeah
yeah I know there's different
personality types but then there's some
flags that are just so deep red that
it's hard to like I this is probably an
unpopular thought but growing up when I
just ran into them I just bullied the
[__] out of them
just like because they looked at I'm
like what the [__] you looking at
I'll be like why are you looking at the
ground and [__] where the [__] are your
eyes going you know
and if they come it's like hey let's
just kick this guy and then you just run
up and just start kicking them and then
like they'll be like ah then they run
away you know hey yo let's get it come
in a lot of ways scared of you or some
[__] in a lot of ways though that's like
they're just like oh dude there's that
freaking scary Japanese dude it's like
what the [__] I was a skinny ass guy no
when you're like 16 you're like a scared
Chihuahua right so you just bite before
you bark like you're just scared I
understand that so like for me I'm like
I'm just like oh this guy's making me
hella uncomfortable I don't want him to
be around here it's still your fear
responses yeah but like in a lot of ways
that's like one of the best ways to just
keep things in check I remember back
then I didn't know what a schizophrenic
was just if a guy's yelling I just like
push him yeah I remember
I remember
oh my God and a lot of my older homies
were in Boy Scouts too because they're
trying to like go like Special Operation
[__] yeah and then we have this guy's
named Lawrence
he walked into like the Boy Scout
meeting like this
is like hey put your pants down man you
see Lawrence like
but then it was just like it just kind
of kept Society in check you know
it's a Bizarro world but it's just like
it's just like if you're just weird
outside the edges it's just like just
get back in the middle yeah that's true
yeah yeah yeah it's like anything that
goes too far off like you're just
bringing it back into the center
someone's like acting all weird I'm like
hey stop acting like that
yeah yeah for real that's that's kind of
like when they go into these details
about how these you know people were
acting it's reminiscent of that a little
bit just a little Bully light move just
we're so sensitive what's light bullying
how do you like like that you don't pull
your [__] pants down yeah you don't
like to your ankles really bad guy yeah
you don't like beat them up no but you
like let them know like you know we're
not gonna accept you the way you are
why are you wearing that like I think
that's okay because then it teaches
people how to like get comebacks you
know why are you wearing that and then
what's the best comeback to them your
mom gave it to me that's good your mom
dressed me this morning that's good no
one okay
foreign